Make sure you have downloaded and extracted the zip file provided for this class. Open the project named Cinematics Arc if you'd like to follow along.
The project is mostly the same one that you used in the Sequencer for Architecture class and contains several saved levels.
If you load the final scene, the level named 04 Cinematics Render, you see an architectural dwelling with a few characters in a plaza.
If you go into Play mode, you get a sense of what you are trying to achieve.
The previous Sequencer class takes care of the character animations,
as well as the animated time of day and the lights coming on towards the end of the animation.
In this class, you learn to set and animate various camera shots and arrange them to play in a certain order in Sequencer, as seen in the playback.
Exit Play mode when done and load the map named 01 Cinematics Cam Pan.
You still have the characters and light animations, but this will be your starting point to create various camera shots.
Select and load the level sequence.
You can see the current animated tracks, but nothing that relates to camera shots just yet.
To create these camera shots, you first need to create physical cameras. In Unreal Engine 5, you need to create Cine Camera Actors.
Cine cameras are a relatively new addition to Unreal Engine. They are meant to replace the older camera system that had less to offer.
In the Add to Project panel, if you do a search for camera, you'll see multiple options.
Note the two options that read Camera Actor and Cine Camera Actor.
Camera Actor is the older method of working. You can still use it, but as stated before, it's old technology that has less to offer.
As you place a camera actor in the scene, you can see a preview of the camera shot,
but in the Details panel, there's very little in terms of parameters.
You can switch between perspective and orthographic projection modes,
change the field of view,
and fiddle a bit with the aspect ratio, but that's about it.
Delete this camera and try the same with the Cine Camera.
Placement is just as easy, but note how many more properties are available in the Details panel.
You have Tracking settings that enable you to follow another actor,
you can set the film back to match real-world cameras,
choose from various lens settings,
and adjust their parameters,
adjust focal length and f-stops,
and even manually adjust the focus settings for specific shot types.
To test it out, you can right-click the camera and pilot it to place it in the right spot.
You'll notice that you have focus effects already, but you can adjust them further to your liking.
At any time, you can exit or eject Cinecam mode and go back to your perspective view.
You can go back to it by piloting the camera again or by using the viewport menu.
The focus method can be set to Do Not Override and let the post-process handle focus for you.
It can be set to Disable to completely turn it off.
It can be set to Tracking and thus be dependent on an actor you're tracking in the scene,
or it can be set to Manual which arguably gives you the most freedom.
In that mode, you can set the manual focus distance or use the eyedropper to pick a point on screen.
Enabling the Debug Plane makes it easier to view the focus plane.
Right now, the focus is on the background and the dancing mannequin is blurred.
You can change that by adjusting the focal distance, bringing the dancing mannequin into focus and blurring the background.
With cameras in the scene, you can use them to override the post-process volume effects.
For example, you can set the camera exposure to be different from the rest of the scene or maybe decide on a black and white or a stylized shot.
You'll notice that this effect will only influence this camera and nothing else in the scene.
You can toggle the camera effect to see the results or even eject the camera view altogether.
The perspective view and the camera thumbnail show two totally different results.
Now that you have covered the basics of a cine camera, it is time to animate its motion.
In the next section, you'll animate a simple panning motion.
Delete this camera before moving on, you won't need it in the next section.